the mini budget was really the
culmination of the economic policies
that have been put in place since the
brexit vote it's a very particular idea
of sovereignty over economic good sense
we couldn't ship anything to the EU
nothing it's bordering on disastrous the
brexities haven't really formulated a
cogent case as to why brexit is going to
deliver a dividend there is a political
conspiracy of Silence around the effects
of brexit it spans the government spans
the labor party make brexit work the
UK's decision to leave the European
Union is an act on economic self-harm in
terms of prices investment and in terms
of trade we're seeing negative effects
not a pandemic effect not an energy
crisis effect these are very clearly
brexit effects
when the UK voted to leave the European
Union in 2016 it seemed like a simple
decision between leaving and staying
what we've ended up with through many
years of back and forth has been pretty
much the hardest least aligned version
of brexit that you could get we're not
part of the European single Market we're
not part of the Customs Union we just
have a very Bare Bones Free Trade
Agreement and the cost of that have
become clear over time of course those
have been masked by the covid-19
pandemic which shut down economies all
over the world and then the crisis in
Ukraine which has scrambled Global
energy markets helped to drive inflation
but we're just now starting to see the
brexit effect coming through and it's
not particularly pretty
number 20 20 go down in our history as
our independence day
we've got our country back we see it
first of all in terms of the original
vote to leave the EU that sent the pound
down about 10 against our trading
partners and that makes Imports more
expensive it also makes your exports
more competitive but in this case our
exports didn't budge they didn't go up
at all but our import prices went up and
that raised inflation by about two to
three percent so that simply made people
poorer when it's been calculated that
the immediate cost of that was about 870
pounds per household
I'm Danny loughran I'm managing director
of Aston chemicals a specialty chemical
distributor for the personal care
industry all our freight costs went up
everything that's costed in Dollars
around the world became more expensive
if you're paying in Sterling and that
was caused by brexit for many years the
brexit side of the debate felt they won
the argument because there hadn't been
much absolute panic in markets in the
recent mini budget quasi-quarters really
spooked the markets Sterling absolutely
plummeted then subsequently recovered a
bit but more serious was what's happened
to government borrowing costs because
the financial markets have taken the
view that the budget was effectively
Reckless I remember the statement of
we've had enough of experts the mini
budget was really the culmination of the
economic policies that have been put in
place since the brexit vote brexit's
proponents refused to even discuss the
idea that brexit's a factor in the UK's
performance
brexit opponents or remainers want to
pin everything on brexit the truth is
inevitably somewhere in between but to
say that brexit isn't a factor in what
you're seeing in the UK performance is
silly of course it is we're starting to
see a very interesting pattern emerging
comparing Britain with the performance
of other advanced economies
after the pandemic there was a trade
recovery by all the other G7 countries
and Britain's trade recovery has been
more or less flat so the UK fell behind
in its trade intensity one of the other
things you can measure is the drop-off
in the number of trade relationships
between smaller companies in the UK and
therefore in counterparts and that's
important because it tells you something
about trade patterns but also tells you
something about the way that smaller
companies in the UK used to grow by
gradually expanding their business
selling stuff into the European single
market and that's simply not happening
anymore the lse is calculated that the
number of relationships between the UK
and the EU fell by about a third in the
first six months after the trading
Corporation agreement came into Force
the resolution Foundation has calculated
that the long run hit
to wages will be 470 pounds per person
brexit has increased bureaucracy many
small businesses have really struggled
to get to grips with that
I'm Kieran towardy hamster is an organic
Tea Company I mean we import tea from
all over the world and sell it all over
the world we were told that we would
have the most amazing deal we're going
to get our sovereignty and we're going
to keep all the advantages of being the
EU as a business we were dumb enough to
believe that come January last year we
got an order from Italy we shipped it as
normal thinking there'll be a little bit
of paperwork and we'll figure it out and
it sat for 12 weeks in different Customs
houses so the reality was very different
I'm Rob I'm Vicky and we co-founded
Little Star jewelry in 2017 as a husband
and wife team
the plan was always to establish the
brand in the UK first and then Ireland
onwards to France onwards of Germany the
whole question of Brett
Brett come into my thought much because
at no point did I think it would be as
complicated for businesses to grow and
to develop remember when we were part of
the single Market you could throw a box
of tea or a packet of bangers into the
back of a Van in Birmingham and just
drive it to Barcelona or Bonn or
Brussels without let or hindrance now
you can't do that the reality was
January to June we couldn't ship
anything to the EU nothing it's 27
countries they all have different
borders they all have different rules
and we were treated as a third country
and we just had to suck it up
come may I decided I needed to do
something
I said what if I set up on my own entity
in Europe and made that the master
distributor for our company and for our
products
and rather than sending small
Consignments at a time which were very
costly and complicated and time hungry
and resource hungry why not just do one
big Consignment every so often clear
Customs all those formalities vat wants
and then distribute out of the warehouse
to all of your clients in the European
Union that means less business taking
place in the UK and more business taking
place in the European Union it became
just unviable for us to continue to
export from the UK and use the UK as our
European Distribution Hub lorries would
sit there for days on end so we moved
our entire European business to Poland
that immediately halved the amount of
product coming through this Warehouse we
are now using fewer Freight Partners in
the UK more in Germany and Poland paying
our customers duties to EU countries
we're employing fewer people in the UK
and More in Poland it's a reduction in
money that we are paying to the UK
economy we were lucky that we were able
to do that and we've got some agents in
France we're doing really well in the
Netherlands and in Spain all of that has
just
disappeared
we lost so much business overnight with
Holland but it doesn't mean that we have
enough business already established that
we'd go and set up an office in
Amsterdam it's not viable for a business
of our size of two people
getting the product to customers in the
European Union would have been two days
has now become 21 days the only angle
for us around that is to do deals with
Distributors but those people work on
between 30 and 35 margins we're left
with virtually nothing or we let the
business go we got a Dutch sales agent
who opened over 30 doors in the space of
two months was over 30 customers has
become two because only two of them can
actually be bothered with the
implications of what they've got to do
to get stock from us it's just too much
of a headache that is the long-term
danger for the British economy that
smaller companies that used to expand by
starting to move into European markets
which was very easy to do before 2016.
we'll simply just not do that we were
just upsetting all our customers one of
them actually said to us we don't want
to do with the UK anymore and we can
find equal product products from the
within the EU so I'm really sorry it was
a tough conversation we went to a trade
show no European customers came to the
UK Pavilion and we overheard one of them
saying there's no point going there with
brexit we don't even know what's going
to happen so there's no point trying to
build new
alliances with British suppliers the
damage from non-tariff barriers is it
puts the UK behind a wall the European
Union 27 countries that have one set of
rules for the movement of goods people
capital and labor it's broadly more cost
more aggro more uncertainty more delays
less efficiency in some cases a sort of
unequal playing field with competitors
overseas a French company will buy from
Germany because they'll probably be able
to get the same product easier and
without any of the extra costs that
we're having to apply to get it out of
the UK
we design all of the range here and then
we send it out to manufacturers in
Thailand and Hong Kong we have a tariff
for it coming into the UK then have to
pay another tariff when we're sending
out of the UK because it's not produced
in the UK the EU is very bureaucratic
and before that we were within the
bureaucracy and now we're outside of it
the whole story about EU red tape making
things more difficult for businesses
from our perspective as a complete lie
since 2016 business investment has been
growing in all other G7 countries but
not in the UK you can see that for a
very long time business investment was
an upward curve in the UK but since 2016
in particular the brexit vote has been
plateauing and the government's been
trying to rectify this been throwing
lots of money at it they've introduced
something called the super deduction
where you get huge allowances if you
invest in capital and Innovation but it
hasn't really shifted the dial I'm
really worrying for the future of our
economy because in the end investment
drives the capital and the ability for
economies to grow into the future and
some people are saying brexit's not the
only thing by any stretch of the
imagination but something is going on
there might be a small effect that the
UK is a more service sector driven
economy than others but France is just
as much of a service sector economy as
the UK Germany big manufacturing economy
isn't that much more of a manufacturing
economy than the UK and in every other
country we've seen much more business
investment this is the brexit effect
people don't know the direction of the
UK economy inevitably business
investment doesn't grow as strongly
[Music]
we've seen in all areas in prices in
terms of investment and in terms of
trade we're seeing negative effects due
to brexit which we can now pinpoint as a
brexit effect not a pandemic effect not
an energy crisis effect these are very
clearly brexit effects plainly there's
been a huge impact on the British
economy caused by the covid pandemic
equally the supply chain effects of the
Ukraine war particularly on the energy
price it will be ludicrous to claim that
problems based in the British economy
are exclusively down to brexit but what
you can do is draw a comparison between
Britain and other countries we see the
UK pretty close to the bottom of the
league table in terms of the forecast
for economic growth particularly in 2023
so the UK essentially sees no growth at
all and the only country that was worse
than the UK was sanctioned Russia you
can explore the gap between the UK's
performance
which has uniquely suffered brexit and
the performance of other economies that
have not the UK government would argue
that's something to do with the bungee
jump effect of the the pandemic where
Bristol went down then came back up more
quickly and now see things are settling
down again I think it's really easy for
the government to try and push the
brexit effect under the carpet and blame
everything onto kovid and now everything
onto Ukraine I can see it in the figures
and in the way that our business is
operating but we were really hit badly
by brexit last year we've put measures
in place that are detrimental to the
British economy unfortunately but will
help us the office for Budget
responsibility thinks that ultimately
brexit will cause the UK to be four
percent worse off it's about a hundred
billion pounds a year that the the
economy is not producing 40 billion
pounds of tax revenues or so we are
poorer because we're not getting that
economic growth that we otherwise would
have done
the brexiteer notion of a brexit
dividend is often based around the idea
that the UK can have a nimbler economy
it can deregulate the difficulty is when
you deregulate you create a separate
regulatory system the chemical industry
spent 500 million pounds over a decade
registering their chemicals in the
European Union which gave them access to
the British Market in 27 other countries
they're now having to re-register all of
those chemicals for a separate UK
register at a cost now estimated by the
government at 2 billion pounds so what
we've essentially done is ask industry
to spend billions of pounds duplicating
a regime that already existed in the EU
and because we want to be Sovereign we
want to be different we're building our
own but that is just cost I don't
understand anyone who says that
deregulation is going to be a benefit to
Industry for my industry's point of view
it is nothing but extra cost bureaucracy
and work for no Advantage whatsoever
[Music]
it's a British business after we've left
the EU has faced a recruitment crisis
areas like construction Hospitality
social care agriculture again you can
argue till you're blue in the face about
how much of that is brexit how many
people left because of brexit or how
much of that was because of covid some
people would argue that's that's for the
better that we've cut off that supply of
cheap European union labor that was able
to come across to work in the UK under
free movement the idea eventually is
that companies will invest more in
machinery and pro and other ways to
enhance productivity to to compensate
but it certainly caused some disruption
in the short term and the idea that the
government was putting forward last year
that this was all part of the plan to
develop a you know high-skilled
high-wage economy was problematic at the
time and is problematic today so the end
of free movement means that the economy
is reshaped for some Industries like
hospitality and construction
or soft fruit growing that creates a
painful period of adjustment because
those industries were predicated on the
idea that there would be free movement
but ultimately that's a political choice
we don't have to have a soft fruit
industry we had one as a result of free
movement we now have to decide if we
want one going forward
the long-running row over Northern
Ireland creating a border in the Irish
sea to avoid the north-south Border
returning on the island of Ireland has
poisoned EU UK relations the EU is using
us as a negotiating chip and saying that
Britain can't join the Horizon Science
research project which is worth 95
billion euros hugely important to
British scientists and British
universities but it's blocked because
the British government is trying
unilaterally to rip up its obligations
in Northern Ireland while we have that
attitude still in place I think it's
very difficult to see our trading
relationships improve the discussion
about Northern Ireland and its future
trading relationship was one of the
things that bedeviled the negotiations
about brexit everybody knew it was going
to be a problem but we did the deal
anyway we voted for brexit we signed a
so-called Northern Ireland protocol
which Boris Johnson and Lord David Frost
the former brexit Minister who
negotiated the Northern Ireland protocol
I spent the last several years trashing
I seems to think it's become for some
surprise that the European court of
justice applies EU rules to Northern
Ireland when they have agreed that
Northern Ireland should remain as part
of the EU single market for goods one
thing I'd say about the northern
protocol is it's given Northern Ireland
an incredible trading position in Europe
it's the only place in the whole of
Europe which has one foot in the UK
single market and another foot in the
European Union single Market it's an
unwelcome fact for brexiteers that
Northern Ireland has become a economic
success story booming certainly in terms
of inward investment one of the reasons
it's doing well is because it has a
place in the European single market for
goods there's exactly the same trading
position with the European Union that
the whole of the UK had until a couple
of years ago
there is a political conspiracy of
Silence around brexit and the effects of
brexit it spans the government spans the
labor party in particular it's very hard
to separate out the effects of covert
and the effects of brexit the governor
of the bank of England doesn't want to
talk about it there's become a kind of
taboo around this whole subject we
absolutely need an honest debate about
the economic effects of brexit once you
had a government of whichever party
willing to look at facts then they could
start saying it looks as if brexit has
hurt us it's making you poorer this is
what our evidence suggests the evidence
will say that by the way and then once
you say that to the public and keep
repeating it you can start opening the
debate politically the truth is neither
party can be honest about brexit the
Tory party doesn't want to be honest
that the actual choice that brexit
presents is between being a rule taker
between subjugation like Norway and
self-harm which is all the economic
damage that comes from Walling yourself
off from your nearest and biggest market
and the labor party doesn't want to talk
about brexit because it reminds voters
why they voted Tory the labor party is
the Tories frame it try to block brexit
this is still a live rail in British
politics people don't want to go
anywhere near brexit it's divided the
country it's divided communities it's
divided families but in a way that
Shields us from a debate which we should
be having about how we can make brexits
function in a way which doesn't distort
the economy
people who speak out against brexit are
often decried as ramonas or romaniacs
we're all being asked to accept
something which in 2015 was only the
official policy of the UK independence
party
server to party the labor party liberal
Democrats greens trade unions the CPI
the whole of British political and Civic
Society believed Britain was better off
inside the European Union and yet we are
all being told we have to pay Allegiance
this is a new National policy
I expected that to be a one year down
the road recap what went wrong and what
was right and how we can fix it but we
haven't seen that
it would be really good to hear what
other people's experiences have been
there might be some good news stories I
don't know I haven't heard any I find it
hard to think of anyone who said this
has been brilliant for my business
some businesses will win as a result of
brexit businesses that can produce
products for the UK Market that are now
too complicated or too difficult to
import from the EU that doesn't
necessarily mean that the UK economy is
winning eu-based companies that have
gained some of our contracts the EU
freight companies that are gaining our
Freight business that isn't in the UK
anymore they're all doing quite well the
people in Poland that we've had to
employ in warehouses rather than people
in the UK they're doing quite well
in theory the city of London is a place
where the UK being able to make its own
rules should be important this is our
sector that we're the best at that we
know about most about we were
responsible for a lot of rulemaking
while we were within the EU to date we
haven't seen the results of that the
predictions of Doom for the city of
London were always overdone big
institutions in particular spent time
actually quite early on in the process
brexit proofing their operations so that
they could operate legally whatever the
outcome was what we've seen since then I
think is a slow drip where business and
people get relocated to other places
where it makes more sense for them to be
the city was the natural place to do
Financial business in Europe and brexit
introduced a question mark into that we
weren't given enough information we
weren't told what brexit would actually
look like
losers will be some of the younger
people who voted against brexit if you
look at the age profile of people who
voted leave as a vote amongst the older
members of the population
[Music]
the younger generation will start to
discuss this topic they can't travel
easily anymore they need a nomad Visa if
they want to work in Europe they can no
longer invest in Europe easily and with
the geopolitical situation on a knife
edge
it would be nice to be a part of a
bigger group and I feel sorry that we
aren't for the Next Generation don't
talk to people who are not rich
remainers Britain leave the EU on time
sure you certainly hear conservatives
who say that if you can't demonstrate
the benefits of brexit by the next
election you're going to be in serious
trouble and so you have the creation of
jobs like brexit opportunities Minister
leaving the European Union is the most
fantastic opportunity of the United
Kingdom the benefits of brexit always
just around the corner this happened six
years ago by now somebody in government
given the fact this is a brexity a
government should have identified what
the benefits are the brexiteers haven't
really formulated a cogent case as to
why Walling the UK off from its largest
market on its doorstep will lead to a
better economy when the government
Unleashed its brexit opportunities
document what was the number one item
that you were going to have a crown
stamp back on your point what in the
English pub the vote leave side
presented a very optimistic view of what
the British economy would look like
after brexit including a massive series
of deregulation Britain buccaneering
around the world striking trade deals
around the world there have been some
trade deals but they've mainly been with
countries that Britain already had a
trade deal with through the European
Union Australia really is the only one
exception to that signing a free trade
agreement with New Zealand or Australia
has ups and downs of the UK economy and
is probably very very marginally
positive but it's nothing like losing a
free trade agreement and losing the
frictionless trade you had with your
biggest trading partner that's only 20
miles away across the channel we lose
four percent of our GDP by brexit we
gain 0.08 by the government's own
estimate through this trade deal with
Australia all all the attempts to lay
out exactly what a brexit dividend looks
like have thus far been totally
unconvincing and that's on the trade
agreement front on the regulatory front
or the deregulatory front the best case
scenario is that a brexit dividend is
lots and lots of little changes that in
aggregate add up to something meaningful
there's no sort of great idea that is
out there at the moment when the
brexiters said or brexit will unleash
Britain's Global potential that made me
very annoyed because we weren't sitting
on our Laurels just easily selling into
France everyone was already doing that
we were already trading with the whole
of the rest of the world making things
more difficult for us to sell into you
did not make anything easier
again and again on and on it goes but
that all the aspects of project fear so
far have been wrong we were promised a
punishment budget that never happened we
were promised an increase of
unemployment by 800 000 by voting to
leave that did not happen remainers give
themselves no service by claiming that
immediately after a brexit vote that
Britain's economy would crash into
recession and millions of people would
be unemployed I mean that hasn't
happened and probably was never going to
happen the project fear tag
was very effective from the leave
campaign and lost to this day I think
the trouble is that brexit's boring and
detailed and wonky it was hard to talk
about that wonky detail around trading
arrangements and Customs unions and
paperwork in a political campaign
brexit done it was one of the most
effective election slogans you've seen
we didn't even start to dig into those
questions until after the vote was
finished
the type of brexit we decided to pursue
was economically the most harmful there
was always a spectrum of economic impact
versus ability to make our own choices
around things like regulation the
European Union is not a superpower in
the way the United States is a
superpower but it is a regulatory and
trading superpower collectively it's the
world's largest market and it harmonized
all of its rules to allow everybody to
trade more freely and it forced other
countries and and trading blocks to
follow EU rules in many ways we can no
longer blame European rulemakers for
decisions and policies that we don't
like or outcomes that we don't like in
our own economy with sovereignty comes a
degree of ownership
I think we can conclude one that brexit
was an act of economic self-harm two
that the losers will be the nation as a
whole but also some of the poorest
people because ultimately we are poor as
a nation that hurts more vulnerable
people more third I think something from
economics we can say is that we can't
run referendums on very simple economic
slogans and it's dangerous to try and
weaponize economies
brexit is a slow puncture it's not a car
crash so that doesn't mean that brexit
creates an unemployment crisis in the UK
but it may mean that over time UK
workers find themselves in less
productive jobs and that makes the
economy smaller than it otherwise would
have been it makes wages lower than they
otherwise would have been the slow
puncture analogy has been right from
2016 but I think the mini budget is that
first sign that if we push things too
far not only are you gonna begin to hear
much more of an audible hiss
but you might even have a blowout it's
bordering on disastrous I don't think
there's any real public awareness of
this even if we go and visit my mum for
a weekend and talk to her about the
difficulties we Face she'll go oh really
I thought we had a deal the things ever
in the news about it everybody else
seems to be voicing any any concerns
apart from maybe you on Twitter
[Music]
brexit wasn't all about the economy it
was about stopping the free movement of
people it was about repatriating a sense
of agency into the UK economy the
trouble was the brexiteers and those who
sold it were not honest about the
trade-offs and the costs of that which
actually economically outweighed the
benefits it is legitimate to have a
discussion about National sovereignty
and taking back control you could have
had that argument but you have to accept
that there will be some economic impact
the trouble was you know Boris Johnson
famously
Dr the cakist approach have your cake
and eat it cake is a more cherry picking
as Michelle barnier used to call it this
idea that you could retain all the
access you wanted to the EU single
market and still be free to go off on
what you might call your buccaneering
brexit it was that cake ISM that was
slowly but surely exploded by the
process of negotiating with the EU and
we're still paying the price of that
really because people have never been
prepared to accept or identify the
trade-offs and then start talking about
what you can do about it
[Music]